>> Laura: UNBELIEVABLE.
ED, THANK YOU SO MUCH TONIGHT.
JOINING ME NOW EXCLUSIVELY IS
ACTING ICE DIRECTOR MARK MORGAN.
MARK, CBT IS SAYING WE'RE IN A
FULL BLOWN EMERGENCY.
SEEMS LIKE WE'VE BEEN HEARING
THIS FOR A LONG TIME.
SIX WEEKS AGO WHEN WE WERE DOWN
THERE IN THE SOUTHERN BORDER IN
TEXAS, THAT SECTOR, WHICH
USUALLY IS PRETTY SMALL IN
TERMS OF BORDER CROSSINGS WAS
BURSTING AT THE SEAMS.
NOW IT'S EXPONENTIALLY WORSE.
WHAT MORE NEEDS TO HAPPEN FOR
CONGRESS TO GET THIS AND DO
SOMETHING TO SECURE THE BORDER?
>> SO LAURA, THAT'S THE
QUESTION.
WE'VE BEEN SOUNDING THE ALARM
FOR A VERY LONG TIME THAT THIS
IS ABSOLUTELY HUMANITARIAN AND
NATIONAL SECURITY CRISIS.
CONGRESS HAS FAILED TO DO THEIR
JOB.
LAURA, IT IS UNBELIEVABLE TO ME
THAT WE'RE STILL ASKING ACROSS
THE BOARD WHAT CAN CONGRESS DO?
WHEN WE'VE BEEN TELLING
CONGRESS, THE EXPERTS LIVING
THIS EVERY SINGLE DAY FROM ICE
TO THE BORDER PATROL, CBP.
THEY NEED TO PASS MEANINGFUL
LEGISLATION THE FLORES
AGREEMENT AND THEY DO FIND.
FUND BED SPACE AND THIS CRISIS
ENDS TOMORROW.
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY NEED TO
DEVELOPMENT WE'VE BEEN TELLING
THEM.
THEY REFUSE TO DO WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO.
>> Laura: NOW, MARK, WE'RE
LEARNING EVEN MORE ABOUT WHAT
YOURS AND OTHER AGENCIES ARE
DOING FOR THESE MIGRANTS.
NOW, HHS HAD BEEN OFFERING
ENGLISH LANGUAGE COURSES, LEGAL
SERVICES, BILINGUAL SERVICES,
VARIOUS FORMS OF ENTERTAINMENT
FOR THOSE WHO WERE APPREHENDED
ESPECIALLY THE YOUNG PEOPLE.
NOW CBP IS NOW TRYING TO BUY --
PURCHASE 2.2 MILLION DIAPERS
FOR THESE MIGRANT KIDS.
I SAW IT BEING AT THE BORDER.
THESE ARE DESPERATELY NEEDED
BECAUSE AGENTS THEMSELVES ARE
ACTING AS CARETAKERS.
THEY'RE NOT CARETAKERS BUT
HAVING TO ACT AS CARETAKERS.
SO WHAT DO YOU SAY TONIGHT TO
DEMOCRATS LIKE ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ WHO WANTS TO
ABOLISH ICE BECAUSE SHE THINKS,
WELL, ICE ARE THE BAD GUYS, ICE
NEEDS TO GO BECAUSE THAT IS NOT
HUMANITARIAN, NOT HUMANITARIAN
EFFORT.
>> POLITICIANS LIKE THAT,
LAURA, THAT ARE MISINFORMED AND
THE RHETORIC.
IF YOU TALK ABOUT ABOLISHING
ICE, IT IS ABSOLUTELY
IRRESPONSIBLE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT A HOMELAND
SECURITY SIDE, INVESTIGATION
SIDE OF ICE.
LAST YEAR ALONE 34,000 CRIMINAL
ARRESTS, 5,000 GANG MEMBERS
ARRESTED.
THOUSANDS OF CASES OF CHILD
SMUGGLING EXPLOITATION, HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
THEY SEIZED $1.2 BILLION IN
U.S. CURRENCY FROM ILLICIT
ACTIVITY.
I WOULD LIKE TO TALK TO THAT
YOUNG CONGRESSWOMAN AND HAVE
HER TELL ME WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN IF ICE IS ABOLL ISHD ON
THAT.
ENFORCEMENT AND REMOVAL
OPERATION, 66,000 INDIVIDUALS
HAVE BEEN REMOVED FROM THIS
COUNTRY, LAURA.
90% OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
REMOVED EITHER WERE CONVICTED
OF ADDITIONAL CRIME OR CHARGES
PENDING.
WHAT I WOULD SAY TO POLITICIANS
LIKE THAT, YOU NEED TO GET
INFORMED AND STOP THE RHETORIC
OUT THERE BECAUSE IT'S NOT
DOING ANYBODY ANY GOOD.
>> Laura: MARK, IT IS
PURPOSEFUL DENIAL.
IT IS OBVIOUS TO ANYONE WITH
THESE STAGGERING NUMBERS, 32%
INCREASE, 140,000 PEOPLE
CROSSED THE BORDER JUST IN THE
MONTH OF MAY AS WE JUST HEARD
FROM ED.
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE JOE BIDEN
SAYS THE FOLLOWING AT THE
CRISIS AT THE BORDER.
>> THIS IS ABOUT -- AND THE
IDEA WE'RE TRYING TO SCARE THE
LIVING DEVIL OUT OF THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC, MY GOD, HOARDS
ARE COMING.
IT IS SIMPLY -- THIS IS A
CRISIS CREATED BY TRUMP, A
CRISIS CREATED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THAT'S WHY
THEY KEEP COMING.
>> Laura: THE CRISIS IS CREATED
BY TRUMP, MARK.
>> LAURA, THAT IS ABSOLUTELY --
LOOK, I'M TRYING TO CHOOSE MY
WORDS CAREFULLY HERE BUT THAT
IS ABSOLUTELY ABSURD.
THE CRISIS IS BEING CREATED BY
OUR BROKEN ASYLUM LAWS THAT
TELLS PEOPLE YOU GRAB A KID AND
THAT'S A U.S. PASSPORT INTO
THIS COUNTRY AND ONCE YOU GET
HERE, YOU ARE GOING TO STAY.
LAURA, RIGHT NOW WE HAVE PEOPLE
THAT ARE RENTING KIDS.
THEY ARE RENTING KIDS, COMING
ACROSS.
THEN THE FACILITATORS ON THE
AMERICAN SIDE ARE SENDING THE
KIDS BACK TO BE RECYCLED TO BE
RENTED AGAIN TO FORM FAKE
FAMILIES SO THEY CAN COME INTO
THE UNITED STATES.
>> Laura: MARK, WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR MONTHS
AND MONTHS AND MONTHS.
NO MATTER HOW BAD THE FACTS
GET, NO MATTER HOW MUCH VIDEO
WE SHOW, IT IS LIKE IT DOESN'T
MATTER.
SO ALL THEY CARE ABOUT IS
DEMONIZING TRUMP.
LOOK AT THESE CHILDREN ARE
BEING KEPT IN VANS INSTEAD OF
REUNITED WITH THEIR PARENTS
WHEN THE ACTUAL TRUTH IS
CHILDREN HAVE NO BEDS BECAUSE
CONGRESS WILL NOT ALLOCATE THE
MONEY TO EVEN BUILD TEMPORARY
FACILITIES TO KEEP THESE KIDS.
WHAT IS ICE SUPPOSED TO DO,
JUST RELEASE THEM INTO SOCIETY
OR HHS, RELEASE THEM INTO
SOCIETY  TO BE TRAFFICKED?
I'M GETTING A LITTLE SICK OF
THIS.
IT IS FILLED WITH LIES AND
DISTORTIONS ONLY TO DEMONIZE
TRUMP WHEN WE HAVE RUNAWAY
JUDGES THAT CAUSED A LOT OF
THESE PROBLEMS AND A CONGRESS
WHO DOESN'T DO ITS JOB.
IT'S BEYOND COMPREHENSION.
>> I AGREE 100%.
RIGHT NOW WE'VE ASKED CONGRESS.
THEY WON'T PASS THE LAWS THEY
NEED TO TO FIX IT.
WE'RE ASKING FOR SUPPLEMENTAL.
THE CONDITIONS OF BORDER PATROL.
19,000, 4,000 CAPACITY OF
19,000.
2500 KIDS IN THE FACILITIES.
IT IS UNSAFE.
THEY SHOULDN'T BE THERE.
ASKING FOR SUPPLEMENTAL TO HELP
HHS, CDP AND ICE TO GET
ADDITIONAL BED SPACE TO
ALLEVIATE THE HUMANITARIAN SIDE
OF THIS AND CONGRESS STILL
SITTING ON THEIR HANDS.
>> Laura: UNTIL THIS ISSUE GETS